latitude et longitude on les coordonnées
géographiques latitude tout d'abord
commençons ici sur graphique
représentation de gauche alors la
latitude ça se définit par rapport à
l'équateur l'équateur c'est cette ligne
imaginaire qui fasse par le centre de la
terre et qui coupe la terre aux deux
hémisphères égaux je vais prendre cette
équateur comme référence pour définir la
latitude imaginons donc le veuille
connaître à l'attitude de ce point voilà
c'est vous le voyez je veux faire plus
gros un peu grossier et comme ça tout le
monde le mois ce point
à quelle latitude se trouve-t-il bien
c'est très simple je vais regarder
l'angle que la droite qui passe par ce
point et par le centre de la terre fait
avec l'équateur est bien d'accord que
cet angle si que j'appelle alpha fait 30
degrés donc le point qui est situé ici
est à une latitude de 30 degrés c'est
valable aussi pour ce point-ci pour ce
point là pour ce point-là plus comme ce
point là celui ci celui-ci ou celui-là
ou encore même celui ci ou bien celui là
tous ces points sont à une latitude de
30 degrés par rapport à l'équateur alors
déjà différencier les points qui sont en
bas de ce qui sera ou puisque ceux qui
sont en haut
donc ceci est celui là en fait tout ce
qui est ici tout ce qui est dans
l'hémisphère nord
c'est une attitude nord puis nord temps
d'exposition en bas c'est une attitude
dessus voilà donc j'ai déjà trouvé un
moyen de préciser la localisation de mes
différents points évidemment comme je le
disais il ya une
l'étude de points alors on va utiliser
une deuxième coordonnées géographiques
qui est la longitude la longitude va se
définir par rapport au méridien de
greenwich
je suis pas très droit ne s'est pas
toujours facile de tracer la soul le
mayan greenwich c'est bien une longitude
de zéro degré et je vais pour la même
chose par exemple le point qui est situé
ici vous voyez qu'il est sur le méridien
des 15 degrés qui est distant de 15
degrés par rapport aux mairies des
minutes
ici je serai une longitude de 30 degrés
ici aussi un donc sa mare des deux côtés
comment je vais les distinguer d'un côté
je suis à l'est de l'autre côté je suis
à l'ouest
tout ce qui va être à gauche du méridien
de greenwich est considéré à l'ouest et
tout ce qui est à droite à l'est alors
on s'arrête quand bas une fois qu'on a
fait 180 degrés voyez qu'il faut que je
suis ici la longitude diminuent à
nouveau parce que là je suis passé à
l'est de cochon il ya bien ici
le méridien qui est ici et qui s
prolonge finalement avec le médiane et
180 degrés et qui marque la limite entre
les ducs
vous avez su graffiti si un rappel donc
voyez par exemple s'ils ont pris un
point la nouvelle orléans est située à
30 degrés de latitude nord et à 90
degrés de longitude ouest nord ouest à
mettre parfois symbolisé dans la peau ou
par un w dans tout ce qui est
publication anglo saxon
voilà vous avez la même chose
celui ci avec la longitude si longue et
de 90 degrés celui-ci de 32 ans il ya
deux trois petites choses
à noter pour rappel la latitude donc
c'est l'angle formé entre le parallèle
passant par un point donné l'équateur
l'équateur c'est la ligne imaginaire qui
sépare la terre en deux parties égales
deux hémisphères
le parallèle c'est la ligne imaginaire
parallèle à l'équateur pour la longitude
c'est l'angle formé contre le méridien
passant par un point donné et le
méridien de référence c'est-à-dire un
méridien c'est l'arc le décès qui passe
par les deux pôles et qui passe par un
point donné et le made in which passé
mais bien de référence versement par les
niches attention parce que parfois on va
vous noté des coordonnées géographiques
en systèmes sexage des images
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'ils
sont en basse 60 quand je veux être plus
précis que les degrés on avait par
exemple 15 degrés de latitude nord
mais je suis un petit peu au dessus du
15 degrés mais pas tout à fait aux 16
degrés mais comment je vais faire je
dois divisé mon degré en traction pour
pouvoir être plus précis
a lyon la grève des virgules ok ça c'est
le système décimal mais dans veut dire
dans tout ce qui est angle un angle ça
se mesure toujours un système c'est que
ça j'ai du mal alors peut-être que
parfois pour simplifier vous met dans un
système décimal mais en géographie vous
allez retrouver les coordonnées
géographiques géographique en systèmes
sexage et si mal donc vous avez un degré
qui est divisé en 60 minutes
ce petit sic ça veut dire deux minutes
ça n'a rien à voir avec les minutes de
votre montre de votre réveil et ses
minutes elles sont divisées en 60
secondes et donc un degré c'est 3600
secondes 60 minutes x 60 selon 3600
voiliers qui s'y est fait tout à l'égout
3-6 6-2 l'écran j'ai fait un prix screen
de wikipédia 1c'est
la verrière et vous voyez que les
coordonnées géographiques de la berrière
sont mentionnés en système c'est xavier
simard et bien des minutes et des
secondes
donc il faut que ce soit très clair
entre vous et moi
après 5 degrés 59 minutes 59 secondes
c'est pas 5° 55 minutes 60 secondes
c'est 6 degrés c'est le même système que
les heurts puisque les heures en tout
cas leur étant base c'est que ça j'ai du
mal
donc on compte en bas à 60 mais parfois
le système décimal est d'application
vous voyez ici effet un print screen de
les différents séismes qui ont lieu en
italie
on va travailler là-dessus en troisième
année voyez qu'ici la latitude
ça dépasse les 60 donc c'est 42.87 ça
veut dire 42.87 en fait ici le mentionne
embase décimales avec des virgules
comme on a l'habitude on peut passer de
l'un à l'autre c'est pas très compliqué
en fait une fois qu'on a bien compris
comment ça marche
on compte en 10e et un centième de degré
un système décimal et donc 5 degrés 30
minutes
ça devient 5,5 de gain pour passer des
minutes au degré décimaux on multiplie
des décimales par 60 vous voyez que dans
5 6 g 5 5 degrés je prends le 05 puisque
cinq salles astérix devient donc je
prend 0,5 je vais x 60 et j'obtiens 30
minutes
ces 5,2 et ramper nus si je fais de la
culée inverse
je prends mes trente minutes la gelée /
60 et j'obtiens un zoo de halle 5 degrés
ça fait bien au total 5,5 de petites
préparations vous allez prendre le nom
de votre lieu de résidence par exemple
ici c'est faire fi ni
vous cherchez la latitude et la
longitude que vous allez transformer
tout d'abord en faisant passer le nord
au sud et l'est à l'ouest
vous obtenez ici de nouvelles
coordonnées géographiques que vous allez
rechercher sur le planisphère de votre
place vous allez regarder alors ça va
pour l'ensemble d'entre vous ça va se
situer dans cette zone si si je me
trompe pas voilà plus de moi ici
eh bien vous marquer le point dans votre
place de ce qui correspond dans l'autre
hémisphère et de l'autre côté du
méridien à aux coordonnées géographiques
de votre lieu de résidence
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose vous allez changer ses coordonnées
géographiques de base
donc si vous étiez en bas à s'extasie
mal vous passez en base décimales et
inversement
oui si moi j'avais des coordonnées on va
sexage isimat lg 12 / 60 et j'ai obtenu
ses coordonnées à vous de faire
l'exercice
si vous avez question vers sur les idées
pas à me contacter par mail ou alors on
court évidemment bonne fin de journée et
bon travail